I said James I'm sorry
let's just charge this while you stink
she said I'm sorry
you stink
[Music]
guys and girls we're back again and I'm
just gonna go straight for it as per
question of the week and this one's
actually a juicy one juicier than normal
I really like this question the question
was what moment in your life made you
realize turns out Rock Bottom does have
a basement Rob Bottom's got a basement
I've been there oh I'll let you I'll let
you tell us after
I don't even have anything specific I
just felt that okay I'm sure yeah I'm
sure as I'm going along yeah I'm pretty
sure your memory bank is different so
yeah it's different you've got stories
yeah yeah yeah Carol when I surprised
him with lunch after he was hospitalized
he called me and said you're so
unnecessary oh my word
you're so unnecessary
wow it has meanings yeah layers
depending on like that's when like uh
you know when people text you and just
depending on your mood you're reading
three different things yeah yeah
that like that whole you're so
unnecessary could be like oh you're so
extra yeah why are you making all this
effort oh literally you're useless
step in the hospital again facts bro
facts it depends on the mood yeah it
depends on him but he was not in the
mood yeah it depends if I've eaten that
day yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
found my dad dead oh my boyfriend at the
time robbed my house during the funeral
let's go into hell bro
wow yeah during the future during the
funeral mad I mean if there's ever a
time to know there's no one home fast
you know where everyone's gonna be you
literally know where everyone's you know
exactly where they are it's the perfect
time for the Perfect Crime yeah it is I
called her mum begging her to help us
get back together after she cheated on
me
some people have no shame bro no dignity
and no shame no backbone no
self-efficacy yeah yeah just yeah yeah I
haven't used that way today I know
you're a gaster you look to people like
where's that confirmation Professor
South Africa looked at me like yeah yeah
man knows their words still
all the time
has self-confidence jokes yeah bro
that's shameful yeah begged her mum
what's she gonna do a lie she just broke
but please help us talk to her she's not
thinking straight that's long man had
sex with an ex and somehow ended up
sleeping on the porch swing
again dignity facts bro why are you
there
I mean she knows why she went back no no
I mean I know why she went back but why
are you still there to the point where
you're saying sleep outside
she wanted to be as close as possible
she's a joke Bros what she is
I knew my favorite porn videos word for
word
the dialogue word for word wow
the dialogue is crazy the dialogue bro
The Echoes and the sounds that's scary
the little role play they do before yeah
yeah scary I remember when I was like
14 15. yeah yeah I had a go-to vid I
think I did as well
um but yeah I remember as one all I
remember about it was some redhead okay
back in someone's Garden
and the concept of I hadn't felt poem
yet yeah yeah so the concept of pum
outside yeah
in the broad daylight oh you're
free yeah she doesn't care who's
watching yeah yeah that's I must have
watched that 300 times it's nuts to me
outside
that's hilarious yeah yeah
okay
um when I started selling feet picks to
people in person
wow what when I started selling feet
picks to people in person just hustling
yeah you want this do you want yeah I
got this i got this this foot thing
three four five seven of these yeah
Pete mad
the girl of my dreams left me I later
found out she was telling everyone I was
her gay bestie
tough sorry that's um yeah that's that's
actually now I'm actually deep in it
that's that's a that's a new level of
pain that actually is like
hell's got a basement kind of situation
yeah
she never said it was my man dreams left
for me the girl in my dreams left me and
she never she didn't claim me one times
I was a gay bestie
and she's only telling that to the man
that she wants facts
facts oh he's only 10 minutes of the
quote unquote competition
wow
a man pulled Stella on my socks
[Laughter]
oh okay go on a man poured Stella on my
socks so we'll take them off so we could
see my toes
oh wow that's not the route I thought
this was going what rude do you think I
just thought bar fight and he's
antagonizing okay I didn't know this was
that chick yeah yeah
man just wanted to see the feet so he
just pulled beer on our socks I said
take them off
all over the socks I said take them off
take them off they're soaked
but my licked is in they're so there's
french there's wrench take them off dry
them out dry them off we'll try it yeah
wiggle your toes you ever see him
you ever said I feel like I've talked
about it before have you ever seen that
that Tick Tock this is like top five
funniest things I've ever seen where um
I love the video or is this your this is
my opinion
[Laughter]
um
they were like a portal sign yeah and
it's the POV of the guy here I'm pretty
sure he's asking if he could like give a
girl like a foot rub or whatever
can you give me a massage
either
okay he's like oh can I give you a foot
or do you want a foot rubber she's like
no so wait he's got the camera he's
facing out like his POV from him okay
okay and you can see the foot here or
whatever he's like oh let me give you a
foot rub and she's like no and then you
can hear in the back is like
oh I don't want a foot rub either yeah
and it pants and it's just like this
skinny Asian dude look
waiting just I don't remember it's the
most hilarious thing I've ever seen say
less all right what made you what moment
in your life made you realize turns out
Rock Bottom does have a basement
when I paid for a 50p energy drink with
2p coins wow yeah Jesus Christ yeah I'm
50 50p energy drink is is not energy
drink who has 25 2p coins
I also don't remember the last time I
ever saw a 2p coin facts bro
[Laughter]
oh yeah changing his name on my phone to
mum so my friends wouldn't know we still
talk
that's low that is low and like again
like
how can you acknowledge
that this dude is such trash yeah then
my friends can't even find out about
this that's how you know it you just
know you're doing something wrong you're
doing everything wrong you're hiding it
from your brethrens yeah I could yeah
that's but then start from hiding from
you yeah
it that is by basement level like I need
help yeah I need help and I I'm I'm in a
situation that can't get out of an Annex
help but you don't know who to talk to
you can't talk to anyone yeah because if
I told you I'm
if you ever found out something that I
didn't tell you I couldn't tell you just
know I'm look after me yeah
because just know like as betrayed as
you felt yeah
wow say less all right when I had to use
the coupons and food stamps at the same
time
oh dear
that's mad I remember do you remember
the um the McDonald's coupons used to
get like one pound 99 ones oh yeah I
used to rinse them I used to rinse them
as well I used to rinse them in
secondary school yeah you could get like
a if you were lucky you could get like a
big mouth yeah yeah I think my meal for
199 bro oh yeah for 199 it was it was it
was yeah
that's crazy stuff yeah that's like
seven pound now yes it's Bonkers bro
uh when I caught a flat tire and then
locked my keys in the car getting out to
look out getting out to looking sorry I
thought I locked myself out of my car
the other day and the fear the fear I
felt yeah was scary because like um my
car's got
um maybe your car is it as well like
does your car open if you're just in the
area
no so if you're close if I'm close to my
car um if the key is close enough to the
car I don't have to unlock the car I can
just open it I've never tried it it's
weird it only works for the door you're
closest to as well as bear accurate oh
so if I'm
if I'm got the key in my hands and I'm
on the passenger side it will open that
I can open that door sick okay but if
I'm on the passenger side and the key is
here and someone tries to open the
driver's side it won't open okay
um it's interesting but anyway I had my
keys in my bag yeah I opened the boot
yeah dashed my bag in the boot
closed the boot I haven't unlocked the
car yeah yeah yeah close the boot yeah
then went to walk to the the drivers it
was locked yeah yeah I screamed bro what
else I was nowhere near home yeah I was
in London oh
this was this was on Monday before I got
here oh my bro mad I literally in public
was like no no no no no no no I was
yanking a thing knowing exactly where my
keys are oh I was like no no no no no no
this can't happen bro luckily the boot
opened again oh gang oh my God I
literally grabbed like everything I
grabbed my bag and I lent onto the thing
I was just like wow wow like this could
have been ugly yeah
yeah yeah my one is um I think my um if
I ever have if that if I ever get myself
in that situation I can unlock my car
with my phone
with the app yeah I can't
um I need to take my car to the flipping
dealership okay and they have to do some
passcoding to allow it to be unlockable
I appreciate the extra security but who
can be bothered yeah I'm not taking my
car to a dealership to an app
yeah so my app's just been pending I'll
say less
but I've been wanting to do that ever
since that time I dropped my keys in the
cinema I know I just get my hands and
knees find it you did you did I was
ready
you need friends I am bro he was not
letting me I was so embarrassed I was
ready to leave Makita he was ready to
leave and this this car was probably
like maybe two months old yeah it was
brand new yeah you ready to charge the
whole thing just because he didn't want
to get his hand easy to look for it a
movie premiere on the back of it I think
it was black panther black panther yeah
and not only is it hands on my hands and
knees I had to duck my head under
everything yeah my ass was seven foot in
the air yeah yeah he was he was livid
and that's the cinema was packed I was
ready to charge the whole thing I'm just
not going to have my car anymore that's
impossible James you just say that's
impossible and I was like there's no
what's impossible was me getting my
hands and he's in front of these people
that's exactly what you did that's
exactly what I did
all right back to me I've got a few more
you're gonna hate this one all right
anyway accidentally flung my period
blood no on my aunt's wall no no no no
no they're just having shits the first
night
moving on that is moving on yeah my
parents my parents invited one of my one
night stands on a family holiday okay no
die I'd invite him how are my parents
even witnessing this person you're a
one-night facts she was definitely like
Indian or African descent why because
there's a strange person the opposite
sex in this house
it's your fiancee and you forgot to say
something okay that's why they have the
confidence to fight man on a holiday
yeah yeah because it's like otherwise
you don't live here anymore yeah yeah
this is your mind yeah facts facts facts
and I'm surprised you kept him a secret
but like this is your man and we're
going away and and you we'll we'll go
away together so I can get to know him
properly Madness otherwise there's no
reason for him to be here and there's
clearly no reason for you to be here
Madness it can never happen
uh when my girl got pregnant by the guy
I sat opposite work from
tough I don't even know how you figure
that out but yeah
how do you figure that out
wow literally how do you figure that out
wow okay I was sobbing in the shower for
the third time over a man with no job
who lived in a different state
grow up
yeah
come on man yeah bro I can be a son of a
yeah if I make you cry three times
it's your fault it's your fault why are
you coming back to me bro fool me once
I'm clearly bored I'm just having fun
with my life I've got no purpose I know
I've got no prospects bro and I'm just
puppeteering yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you keep coming back in this at this
point it's boring boring I need new meat
I need new blood you're literally bottom
barrower you're wasted yeah and you're
moving like a yo-yo G alive
off and cry stop it man stop it
where's your backbone
add up
oh my goodness oh God we were so broke
we had to pick up cigarette bumpers we
found a bucket that was always in front
of an old person's home we kept taking
them so often they moved the bucket
behind the Gates but that didn't stop us
they put up a sign saying no trespassing
because of cigarette butts you know they
were just taking cigarette butts and
smoking the tiny little bit at the end
yeah from an old folks home yeah there's
just been some a 90 year old's lips are
wrapped around that and you'll win yeah
they were willing to do it oh bro that's
Rock Bottom Magic
that doesn't make sense if you had I'm
just reading take up a different hobby
to reading what the public are saying
fell down fell down the steps and at the
bottom of the steps was my ex and his
new girlfriend they just walked right
past me
[Laughter]
well that's enough to walk past my ex as
she just fell down the stairs and I'm
with my new body
I would
find a way to shank both of the Achilles
tendons yeah I'm shaking both of their
attendance yeah
we're all on the floor and only one of
us getting up
facts only one of us
can you imagine I couldn't I'd be so
angry James I'd be so tackle someone
yeah because you can't there's nothing
you can do like she will always have
that one up yeah because she's literally
seen you at the your lowest point lowest
lowest she stepped over she stepped over
you metaphorically and physically
and upgraded an upgrade and skipped off
of oh skipped off of them I skipped off
with a man
days yeah I'm tackling some way
attendance gone tendon's gone
uh last but not least pretended to fall
asleep at his house because I couldn't
afford the Uber home
I remember I think okay cool so my two
ones in regards to that what to this
specific one or Rock Bottom in general
okay to this that specific one and this
is also probably two of my other Rock
bottoms is Rock Bottom number one was
obviously when I stole that fiber from
that girl yeah because I couldn't afford
the cap home yeah that was kind of robot
on but also like I don't care just get
me home yeah I know you didn't care yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah because like it
wasn't even Rock Bottom in the terms of
like because I would any other day I
would have walked yeah I was in
Halloween costumes yeah yeah and
I've slept in a house yeah I know I just
slept in yeah so it was like midday yeah
mid
um middle of the uh campus yeah
yeah so it's like I'm not I'm not I'm
not dealing with that I can't shame it
that's not even yeah it's not even Rob
bottom it's just like I'm not doing this
yeah I'd rather steal yes I did the
actual bottom was
the actual rock bottom yeah was like
what am I doing was one I did a one
night standing yeah with a girl who was
not attractive okay I must notice sorry
but I'm trying to think of it one she
was not attractive okay two it was in
the middle of the winter
and she was wearing a short skirt on the
night out okay so when I was clapping
cheeks the ass cheeks in the back of the
leg were freezing
and it was the worst thing it was like
banging a bowl of overnight oats it was
just
cold and horrible oh wow so Not only was
she objectively unattractive this is
essentially cold pum as far as my tool
can tell which is impossible so it just
didn't know how to act yeah yeah she
didn't have any lamps or anything it was
Pitch Black you couldn't see your hand
here
so the only impetus I've got is noises
no no no noises and cold cheeks you
could have been clapping anyway you
could have been clapping anyway it could
have been clapping silicone yeah yeah
bro it was awful and I remember being in
it thinking this is the worst I've had
in it I was in there thinking this is
the worst I've had bro was it was she
deaf well the mom death was it no she
was the moms wasn't deaf no no that pawn
was Sublime
that one was a blind but the whole
scenario was
[Laughter]
wow okay yeah no that's a different one
that's another story so this one was
just Rock Bottom yeah
and in the morning I woke up hungover
yeah I had no money in my account and no
way of getting home I build topes oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah bailed him when she
went for a piss yeah bailed him and said
fam I need you to send me money yeah
don't ask me questions yeah don't ask me
questions please I need you to send me
money now
and this is why
he was the only one I could trust the
court because you would ask me questions
he would ask me questions Dave would ask
me none of you man could be trusted with
that level of confidence in that urgency
yeah Joseph is the only one I could
trust to stay cool-headed and send me
the money
cool-headed is the word Toby was the one
who was cool-headed had a new
his pockets were always lined up yeah
yeah yeah he always has paper on it has
money on it so I said fam please send it
to me now and I'll give it back what I
can I've got nothing I've got nothing
bro he just said no sweat yeah yeah no
sweaty just giggled in that Toby little
giggle yeah he said I got you sent it in
minutes
I built a taxi oh God A Better Taxi
immediately bro got home and threw up I
swear got home and threw up almost like
oh what is life yeah I then remembered I
had a PT client this is Saturday morning
now I've got a PT client in five minutes
oh God no I was like
quickly got changed and showered yeah
went to dive in the car I drove my car
the night before
I drove my car the night before so it
was off ends Carl was offense no I had
to run to work
because I could have called Toby again
I had to run
I had to run bro
[Laughter]
that's so funny in winter it's a running
shorts on a t-shirt
I had to run bro and I was did I was
delirious because I was hung over bro I
ran all the way there
as soon as I got in I got in there like
20 minutes late my client was like where
have you been bro I was panicking I said
I'm sorry
[Laughter]
I said I'm sorry let's get to it let's
warm up family warmed up for like five
minutes oh
I said James I'm sorry
let's just charge this way you stink
[Laughter]
she said I'm sorry but you stink
let's just do this next week no fun
I'm just said I'm so sorry
she said is fine I went into the PT
office and sat sat on the chair sat on
the chair and it was a spinny chair and
I was like what am I doing
what am I doing bro I don't have enough
money to support myself I'm running to
work like a madman and my clients are
saying I'm not doing this with you you
smell you stink of alcohol bro
I don't think you understand the visual
yeah I run the whole way
me all for a sloppy wetting up it's not
worth an ice cold nut this was for I'm
risking my career for an ice cold
three out of ten not bro in the pitch
black yeah see that is and now my own
Toby money yeah yeah now worse after
when I'm starting yeah you're down yeah
I only told you money and I always climb
an extra session what am I doing with
myself that's a terrible day wow bro
that's hilarious it was one of the worst
days of my life and I had to walk home
of course and then how did I get my car
how was I getting my car bro
I had to ask my brother to drop me bro
oh no
oh God on his timetable yeah facts not
when I needed it yeah on his timetable
Brock's facts facts oh it was it was the
worst bro oh that is funny thank you for
that thank you for that I needed that
Jesus Christ you're welcome in
it and what's the worst thing anyway
guys welcome
welcome to episode 301 you might be
thinking oh I wish I saw episode 300. I
wish I got to see episode 300 well you
can it's not too late all you need to do
is head on over to patreon.com shits and
gigs and from there you need to donate
contribute pay a very humble three pound
a month don't be a day just quickly run
the pizza sng and indoctrinate yourself
into the cult babies be one of our
babies
that's what we asked be one of our
little cute little pink little babies I
like and you will reap the rewards and
daddy's gonna look hard you're gonna
look after you your daddy's gonna look
after you and um it's cheap as chips
it's cheap as chips cheaper than chips
um so heading over there now guys and
while you're there you can enjoy three
and a half years worth of content on
edited unscripted no ads nothing come up
raw dog over there and while you're at
it you can also join our Sensational
Discord Channel where all the other cult
babies congregate and chat about what's
going on this week facts weekly
catch-ups daily catch-ups chirps in lips
in grips in funny funny yeah all the
above if you are watching us on YouTube
make sure please make sure as of now by
the time this drops we should yeah we're
as as of recording right now we're at
eight nine eight hopefully by time this
drops we should be on the 900 Club and
then it's the final Sprint bro this is
the final hurdle guys we've been talking
about for a few months now we're coming
up to the final Sprint about 1M the last
hundred meters bro is where it counts
the last lap man we need that gold plan
get us there yeah we need that gold
pluck piece come on come on guys please
subscribe to the channel and help your
boys hit a million Subs that's all we
ask it's literally all we ask about a
million we won't talk about it again bam
I've said I'm not gonna speak about it
one more time again we've landed facts
facts we've landed right guys and before
we continue we have a special
announcement to make today
special announcement your boys are
getting into the reaction game content
wow well the reaction content game
whatever you want to call it whatever
you want to call it is funny it's funny
so you know your guys specialize at this
you know she doesn't get specialized in
the reactions and for some reason we've
never made a reaction channel before
we've stayed in our wheelhouse because
we're we're new here we're nervous we
don't know how this man this big man in
the game always have reaction channels
yeah and everyone's like you should do
that too yeah yeah ah there's something
a bit nervous a bit shaky but you know
what we did it we did we did it so
please head on over to shits and gigs
reactions Channel right now there should
be whatever you need popping up bio all
this head on over to our reaction
Channel guys yeah I don't know if it's a
reaction Channel and enjoy our first
episode over there subscribe to that as
well oh God subscribe to that so while
you're helping with this one let's start
on that let's start on that one yeah
let's get there
obviously that live code yeah yeah it's
actually for fun let's just see if we
can just break records yeah
let's do something crazy and hit like
100k Subs in a day or something let's do
something actually Bonkers like that
yeah just do us down favor you man just
just actually just do us a favor if you
don't ask them yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you just ask you to show up yeah yeah if
you like reaction channels or not I
don't care do us a favor and just
subscribe to that one because it will be
so sick yeah if next week when we come
on here again yeah we're like you get to
see our reactions yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know there you go let's try and get
a crazy number of Subs in like the first
week yeah please oh guys that'd be so
sick 100K will be crazy no okay
that's a bit too much I said it first
and then I like I hope you'd ignore it
but you've reiterated it now I'm nervous
but if we did yeah you man that would be
an unbelievable it'll be unbelievable
that would be unbelievable I'm gonna say
I'm gonna say 10K I know you're gonna
say 10. I'm gonna say 10 conservative
ten I'm gonna I'm bougie cause I know
you man I'm gonna listen to us and to
help us get this subscription I'm gonna
go for a young 25. 25k 25k in the first
week in the first week we'll be
bad if we could do that yeah
yeah we would get the reaction channels
are 25k in the first week we'll be bad
bro yeah help us so please do
that guys yeah headed over to the new
channel And subscribe to that subscribe
I'm actually very excited
we won't know until we know
is live reactions literally wow yeah
yeah yeah wow definitely head over there
guys head on over to Russian Channel
guys enjoy that one was fun it's a new
style of content it's a different set
completed um and yeah man we're going to
be banging them out every Wednesday we
are those episodes are going to be
dropping every Wednesday so now you've
got the juicy Monday episodes and head
on over to reaction Channel every
Wednesday guys right it's time it's been
a long time it's been a long time coming
guys REM is back in the building after
his slight Hiatus and we are here for
top five
boards grab your pens unless do it I
know you guys have missed it so yeah man
let's go oh it's been a minute everyone
got their boards everyone got their pens
top five this week is
top five
fastest land animals oh my gosh okay I
wasn't I didn't know you were gonna say
that top okay five fastest land
animals and as per guys at home write in
the comments what you think and when
you're locked in
let me know can I oh I'm prepared for
the answer to be no I'm listening I'm
happy to screen record just for physical
evidence
I can't remember the name of the animal
that I'm trying to think of
if I screen record me Googling just the
name of that thing and not doing
anything to do with fast or anything
like that just so I get the name of the
thing is that allowed or no but if you
forgot the name what you're going to
type in
I know how to get it I I can't say that
because I don't want to give it away
what I'm looking for yeah but I will
show you the screen recorder afterwards
you can show me now I'm an adjudicator
you're an adjudicator
uh okay cool
smells fishy
he's introducible he's a judge it might
not even be in the top five uh I was
gonna just Google this because I know
it's the main uh
that one there
it's the main one
okay does that make sense I know what
you're trying to tell me but I don't
know what
okay yeah if it doesn't it will come up
in the first like five okay options
within that uh that okay so less that's
cool yeah that was fair right that was
fair that was fair all right cool cool
cool cool cool cool cool cool I've done
random ones right okay locks yeah I
think so cool this is gonna be a trick
question you know what I feel like so
basically for context mine are all
completely different animals okay and I
feel like it's just gonna be like
different species within the same okay
animal group I hope not that'll be
really disappointing
we've been disappointed many a time oh
of course this is this is ever
Ellis give me your five please cool so
I've gone for cheetah elephant you might
not think it but they're fast
when was he last chased by an elephant
bro
last week um
gazelle that's a shower horse and a bear
I hope you don't have to do like
specific party no no no yeah
he's not asking he's not asking for
breeds bro yeah I'm jumping over the
cameras
uh REM uh cheetah
gone for dog
whip it specifically
um giraffe
rhino
and horse Jimmy okay I did cheetah
Greyhound
gazelle
because that was the one I had to Google
by the way oh really yeah yeah
[Music]
what was in your mind well I was your
thought process to not being able to get
to gazelle I just couldn't remember the
name I just know what it looked like I
just couldn't remember the name what did
you have to search yeah I typed in what
a lion's hunt I thought you were gonna I
thought you were gonna say
that's literally what I did it literally
Greyhound gazelle horse and polar bear
upper oh I'm taking an airline gazelle
that's damn It's gotta be
there it has to be right actually here
kangaroos are pretty fast actually oh
God Alice you've gone cheetah elephant
gazelle horse bear REM you've gone
cheetah dog giraffe Rhino horse Jimmy
you've gone cheetah Greyhound gazelle
horse polar bear I'll tell you what okay
number 10. ranging from 50 miles to 80
miles an hour to 80. yeah you know
or kilometers not miles oh I'm sorry
that's impossible
no way kilometers an hour is a hair oh
damn good shout yeah
number nine
same range 50 to 80.
gazelle
number eight
a black Buck also known as an Indian
antelope
oh I see now that's family so I'm
telling you bro I think it's going to be
cats and deer yeah yeah I think so cats
and deer is going to be all five
number seven
the cougar ah yeah cats yeah there we go
number six
a lion cat
number five
top speed of 80.5 kilometers an hour a
blue wildebeest
oh wow okay
you know where we'll be says
Lions hunt that too Lions do you
remember the Lion King yeah yeah
remember the Stampede that like killed
me faster
because I have to relate to Lion King
for me to get it uh number four
top speed of 88 kilometers an hour a
springbok
foreign
oh they're like yeah they're smaller
gazelles apparently
here we go the smaller gazelles
apparently yep yep
number three top speed of 88.5
is a pronghorn it's that type of
gazelle as well if it's a cat or a
gazelle walking out
it's a type of antelope yeah bro
same
deer and cats bro number two
top speed of 96.6 kilometers an hour an
ostrich
ostriches are fast yes
and then we've got a cheetah one so no
one got anything but cheater number one
top speed of 120.7
the cheetah
we all got one yeah
so we all got one the next closest was
me and Alice yeah so we dropped out tie
break so you're on a tie break yeah is
there any more after 10 or is it just
top ten you got
um
I can go on to 11 is
a wild dog and only Ram said dog
I said Greyhound if it counts yeah you
disagree on both the Wild dog doesn't
yeah number 12 which what have you said
not in here kangaroo damn who do you see
who said that someone you said kangaroo
in it yeah number 13.
is a horse and you both said horse
okay Jesus this is intense
and number 14 which only one of you said
only one of you said number 14. god I
didn't even I don't even deep this
it was Dennis wasn't it I don't know was
it
you said elephant yeah you said
Greyhound
yeah it's great It's gotta be great it
could be a bear though we'd never know
it's not opportunity
sake yeah let's go
[Music]
I love just dangling everything when you
said you said elephant I was thinking no
way
no way 70 miles an hour top speed of a
greyhound oh damn man
it's oh miles kilometers an hour sorry
damn yeah fair play so yeah that's top
five fastest land animals going so mean
REM even now six six six six two yeah oh
boy it's getting tense it is I've got
one I already know which one I'm gonna
do next week okay Peng is um it should
be fun ggs well played guys yeah very
decent well played indeed right guys
let's take a very very very quick break
as we need to keep the lights on in this
building right so I'm gonna talk to you
very very quickly ladies specifically
about manscapes okay come on and in
particular the landscape performance
package 4.0
this package has everything you need to
prepare for that summer bot
whether you're gifting it to your man or
using it on your bikini line let's keep
your bush tame with the lawnmower 4.0
trimmer let's go their package also
includes the weed whacker ear and nose
here trimmer hair trimmer sorry I know
some of you ladies pretend like they
don't exist but they do we've seen it
and we're not pleased
crop preserver ball deodorant I'm so I'm
sure the good girlfriends out there like
to satisfy their man from head to toe
keep him fresh with the ball deodorant
and the crop reviver toner as well as
those silky soft performance boxer
briefs and a travel bag to hold all your
goodies guys all you need to do for this
bundle of joy is head on over to
manscape.com
and for 20 off and free shipping just
use the code sng Sierra November Golf
and enjoy yourselves let's get back to
the episode
um right before we move on to the
Dilemma of the day yeah
I actually have some like a story not
story time but like a bit of a story to
give context of flowers that I want to
give to you
my Block's my phone I'm intrigued
oh thanks
right so I would like to give flag some
flowers today thank you sir you're
welcome because
you sir are a man of integrity okay and
I'm going to give a story all the way
back and then I need to remember that we
will eventually land on how you have
integrated like say less because the
store has fuckle to do with you
[Music]
so I'm gonna forget why we're talking
less I'm gonna say stuff and forget why
we're talking yeah yeah you might
remember please who had Integrity just
put this yeah yeah yeah yeah right cool
so I'm gonna be lost in your story yeah
yeah I hope so
jokes
um
okay so basically
a few weeks ago
a few weeks ago I got
[Music]
um
a DM right from someone I went to school
with
and I haven't seen her in years okay yes
okay
and she basically sent me a message and
said oh I'm getting married
um and I haven't seen you in a long time
and um getting married abroad but when I
come back I'm going to throw a party
basically I'm assuming for all the
people that didn't come to the wedding
abroad okay and I'm assuming the people
that did come as well but just like a UK
version yeah yeah yeah wherever they're
going thing yeah and that's all right I
haven't I haven't spoke to this person
in so so long and I said oh yeah I'll go
first of all I'm really nervous about it
yeah I'm really anxious about it I would
be too yeah someone doesn't seen him
spoken to me yeah yeah I'm super anxious
about it because I know it's just going
to be a room full of people that haven't
seen in many many years and it's given
me School Reunion yeah yeah and the
awkward thing about it is that
especially because I was from a small
town yeah the awkward about it is that
like a school reunion but everyone knows
what I do every single person in the
room knows what I do in there yeah and
they're going to be waiting to say
something to me yeah you've made it and
they're bumps
sake that's what you're trying to
say I'm not
I'm not gonna take it I just
said let's see now I'm not going
[Applause]
yeah oh me I already know through
the roof because I'm gonna be stood
there like this waiting for people to
say stuff to me there's no questions to
be asked because everyone already knows
yeah and not only does everyone know my
career involves people over it involves
me just saying stuff about my life
anyway there's nothing really to ask
yeah it's just bait so again that's
going to make me really uncomfortable
but that's besides the point
so when she invited me I remember
thinking about basically back in the day
from probably like year eight or year
nine up until up until
probably until we left for uni me and
this girl and not just me and this girl
but my group of friends and her group of
friends were like Inseparable oh nice
group of guys group of girls Inseparable
no one ever clapped anyone like no it
was just dang plutonic friendships
Sensational friendships and the one
thing about this girl I loved her to
death and I was probably at one point or
another I was closer than with disco
than I was with any other girl I would
go to a house all the time we would have
sleepovers at our house and her mom
was the nicest and it was just cool she
had a trampoline in the back no one else
did
um
yeah I was up in there yeah yeah um but
anyway we had a really really good
friendship yeah
and I remember one of the things with
this girl one of the traces ago I had
that I hated at the time
was that she
and I I've realized later on in life
that a lot of girls had this and some
guys have it but it's more it's more
like prominent in girls like when girls
get into a relationships yeah
they're willing to cut off everyone yeah
and
there was a running theme with this girl
and it used to break my heart every time
she'd do it is that when she'd get into
relationship she would cut the guys off
out of respect for a boyfriend she would
cut the man them off and we just weren't
her friend anymore should say we were
friends yeah yeah but she won't move it
like we were friends she won't talk to
us anymore we're not allowed to come to
the house anymore like don't be texting
her out the blue anymore because it's
sarson all this kind of that she
would do to Pander to her relationship
which I can understand they used to
break my heart yeah and then every time
they should break up with a boyfriend
we're back to normal and then we'd be
normal for like a year and then she'd
get another boyfriend and it'll be the
exact same thing all over again so I was
just like losing my friend gaining my
friend wishy-washy yeah wishy washy
friendship it used to hurt me so
sometimes and then in between boyfriends
I'll cuss her and yeah yeah yeah but I
was being serious but she would think
it's a joke and all the manual cuss her
and she'll be like oh shut up like what
am I supposed to do as a boyfriend and
like it would hurt me yeah
um and I when she I forgot all about
this until she missed me the other day
and I was like
obviously water in the bridge I don't
care yeah um but it just reminded me and
I had another friend that you know okay
who is like that as well
okay oh yeah yeah yeah and um
she cuts me off every time she has a
boyfriend what makes it I remember what
made it worse we spoke like maybe a year
ago whatever and I brought it up
and to said person to said person okay
we're speaking
um she'd call me out the blue whatever
and we're speaking and I brought it up
and what made it worse is that she made
the fact that now because of who I am
she definitely ain't telling her
boyfriend that we're friends
um and it hurt me even more yeah yeah
and I was just like this is
yeah because me and this girl at a
certain point were very very close yeah
I know yeah it's only happened to me
personally with those two girls but I
know it happens a lot and I was speaking
to someone the other day and they told
me like a proper like serious story
about how it happened to them they had
to like
the person that was cutting them off had
to actually break it down wasn't even
doing it's like subliminally or anything
like that actually had to like
physically break it down to them and be
like I'm sorry yeah
but this is how it is
And my partner's not comfortable with
this friendship yeah and these these two
people were like again Inseparable like
bredger and Brethren yeah it's like it's
just not gonna run and it's causing
friction in my relationship and
I'm sorry but you're out kind of thing
because I want this relationship to work
damn it's tough sounds it
so when I was thinking about this thing
that happened to me with these two girls
that I was friends with and I was
thinking about the story that this
person told me yeah that happened to
them yeah and I was thinking you know
what yeah first of all it actually
pisses me off that people are willing to
do that and I understand why they're
willing to do it yeah
but like for me it infuriates me so much
because it's like
I would never forgive the person who's
willing to let me do that so if I had a
girlfriend
and I had a really really close female
friend completely platonic and the
girlfriend said
ah
I'm not comfortable with this
relationship bear in mind this I've been
best friends with this person for years
and we're cool and nothing's ever
happened like her uncomfortableness is
is purely her problem like I haven't
done anything and if I was to explain
how serious this friendship is to me
and then the girlfriend turned to me and
be like well I'm not comfortable with it
so I want her out of your life yeah if
the if she then let me cut her out of my
life and then just sat there and let it
happen she's not the person I even want
to be with facts like you're a selfish
like who are you like you're
willing to actually let me like cut
limbs off my body yeah just because
you're uncomfortable yeah and then once
it's done like what like where's the
cons where's the consolation like what
am I doing I'm just without a friend and
you're just like
like it doesn't matter to you
um but anyway so all that all that it
made me deep and then I started thinking
about you
and how I've realized that in multiple
multiple situations
you refused to change any aspect of your
relationship with Bella when you guys
were living together and I know from you
telling me and from her telling me that
like it caused friction in pretty much
every single relationship that you ever
had and not even just relationship like
every girl that you were seeing and you
reverse situation it could be yeah yeah
any situation from one night stand to
flip in girlfriend
caused friction with every single person
and you dealt with it like without
budging an inch
for multiple years yeah
and I read it thank you Jim you're
welcome thank you G I feel like it's
it's weird as well because I think
because it doubled down because I lived
with her as well yeah and because a lot
of people would never
expect
um a single male a single female to live
together platonically and never do
anything yeah yeah in some people's
world it's inconceivable
so for me to know it's very doable and
be like listen this is how I feel like a
lot of people need to live this way and
I have a lot more friends this way yeah
yeah friends is it makes a lot of sense
it's gas it's gang it makes so much
sense so for you to be so selfish and
think ah
it's not even selfish I think it's a
it's a form of insecurity because I
remember there was a girl I was quote
unquote seeing
um this was probably within the first
year Bella and I were living together
um she said something along the lines of
I don't believe you look at her she's so
pretty how could you not something along
those lines yeah yeah
that's got a all to do with me he
sounds like a projection on yourself
yeah this is an insecurity that you're
pushing onto you're pushing on and it's
like you want me to bite yeah it's like
I'm not gonna bite on that like this is
a fret I've told you she's my friend
you've seen us or you've been in the
yard when me and Bella are in the yard
you know so how can you assume something
more has happened yeah yeah so uh it was
it was it was an ordeal but I it was one
of those ones I always knew my
friendship with Bella would always
supersede all these girls I was with
yeah and yeah man as long as I knew that
it was it didn't bother me if they felt
some type of way okay I really didn't
bother I'm glad to hear it and uh on
that point I'm actually gonna give
secondary flowers because I've had a
well we've had there's a female friend
that we have all together she's never
done it uh Chloe yeah I think you're
gonna say yeah Chloe's had
this is not top he's had a few
boyfriends yeah she's like a couple
boyfriends in our in our tenure
um but we've known her for like uh uh I
think I met her when I was 19. yeah over
a decade
um so yeah 13 years yeah and in all that
time she is never once come close to it
um so Props to her yeah she takes thugs
as well
she dates roadmen so yeah if anyone's
gonna do it yeah yeah it's her yeah so
yeah props to her man and she's probably
not listen in and we'll never hear this
but thanks for that because it actually
makes a massive difference because when
people have done it to me it
hurts bro yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
hear him he's jarring and also again
props the Bell if I never doing to you
facts yeah because I'm sure she dealt
with the same yeah to a degree yeah
to a degree yeah but yeah I remember
there are times they would she would
obviously tell me after the fact but
they would ask her oh is he gay
very it's so inconceivable
living in the same roof they have to be
back yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's like wow like you men are so
you're so fickle-minded you know what I
mean yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
I think from from the first from the
first instance it happened with the
first person I was seeing in my first
yard with Bella I was like this can
never happen again I'm never gonna stand
for this again yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I've told you my truth yeah and
you're choosing to believe what your
mind tells you yeah facts based on zero
evidence based on nothing based on what
you just see yeah and you're you're
basically insecure so I'm not I'm never
dealing with this again gang fair play
well played it was always going to be oh
God right you've got to deliver for us I
do have a dilemma guys I need your help
with this issue I need some advice
I'm 28 who was with his ex for eight
years
we have three kids only one is mine
she already had a kid when we got
together and I took on the role of a dad
about three months in
we were together for about four years
before she fell pregnant with my son
then we stayed together for about
another two years after he was born and
then we split up for about six to seven
months and within that time she ends up
falling pregnant by another guy
she told me about it when she stays
being pregnant what the she told me
about it when she was five months
pregnant and she was telling me how
sorry she was now she wished they had
been me or and all of that stuff I chose
to take the baby on and chose to take
the baby on as my own and raise the
child and we got back together and only
split up last year however this is where
it gets a bit complicated the child's
biological father is now back on the
scene after she promised she wouldn't
let him be a part of the child's life
now we aren't together anymore she's
being nasty and and now that we're not
together anymore she's being nasty and
anything I say is wrong and now it's
come to my attention that he was trying
to force me out of the child's life and
doesn't want me to have anything to do
with my daughter
what and doesn't want me to have
anything to do with yeah with what is my
daughter sorry having been the dad for
her entire life my bad this is it's been
a year yeah pretty much okay
um I also feel like she's going to cut
me out what do I do let me recap uh he's
28 years old
um been together with his ex for eight
years and they have three kids one of
them is his own only
um
she had the kids in a past relationship
and then three months into getting into
the relationship with her
um she got she got pregnant they were
together about four years uh so no three
months in
is when she decided he decided to take
ownership of this the first the first
youth that was someone else yeah four
months into their relationship she got
pregnant with their son so a month after
he's so he's recruited one you yeah he's
three months in yeah he's been they've
been dating for 12 weeks yeah he's
recruited the first year he said gang a
month after that she's pregnant with his
you yeah gang yep then how long uh we
were together for about no no so three
months in this when she took the role of
the first ad of the first you that's
what I said yes about four years after
that four years after he said four
months four years after that is when
they had their first son oh wow okay
then they stayed together for about two
years
um and then he split up for about six to
seven months she got pregnant by another
guy and only told him when she was five
months into that pregnancy that she's
pregnant and that she should have been
quote unquote should have been his I'm
sorry blah blah blah
um back now she chose to take um he came
back they're back together he chose to
raise that third baby as his
um but they then again split up it
became complicated because the
biological father wanted to be back into
the daughter's life
um and now that they're together now
they're not together she's being nasty
towards him and
um
anything he says apparently is wrong and
she's trying to ask if
um basically ask what he's what he
should do and she's he said he feels
like she's going to cut him out Okay
cool so I've met a thing yeah she's
banging yeah she's got uh she's got a
kid she has a kid
Anonymous age we don't know yeah he's
got a kid we've been dating for three
months after three wonderful months I'm
like you know what this kid's all right
yeah I'm having this kid too yeah I've
got my girl and her kid and we're a
happy family yeah we're a happy family
for four years after this it's a long
time four years later bang pregnant with
my you say less
so now you're pregnant with my you we
have my you Sensational we then break up
after two years after two years so
now while we're away
I'm
you've got your you who I claimed as
mine you've got my you that actually is
mine and then while we're out you're a
little some and then you you've got now
next man's you so now you've got next
man's you
we get back together and you're saying
look
I've got this view by next man but he's
out the picture he's never coming back
in the picture what are you saying I
whom clearly a mug takes on this second
you immediately yeah and says cool I'm
gonna raise it as a our own we live like
this for a year yeah we break up again
yeah so now there's two use that aren't
mine that I claim and one you that is
mine they obviously claim with breaking
up broken up for a second time and
during this she found herself stumbling
back to our homeboy yeah
who and now she's saying brother I don't
think this is gonna work out and he said
that the the real dad is also saying
come out on my used life yeah and he's
saying that's my you yeah and he's like
big man chill it's really nice actually
it isn't
it because there's bad use in here yeah
I really wanted the most like you yeah
yeah yeah mixed race yeah yeah yeah yeah
who's even your girl to be fair facts
who's even your wife yeah
um he said what do I do do I do she's
being vicious gonna squeeze me out he
thinks she's gonna squeeze he thinks
he's he's concerned that she's gonna
squeeze him out and cut him off
it's a tough tough tough tough situation
but
actually there's no but but I'm saying
but for lack of a better word but
this is actually like
a gripe for me okay I know guys that
likes quote unquote Step Up have like an
aura of Purity around them and they're
on pretty much bulletproof but like
there's risks to stepping up of course
there's risks when I sometimes stuff
like this I never understand when like
uh guys start claiming news that aren't
theirs and letting the youth call them
dad and all this like I understand
like you're a family and all this kind
of stuff but for this specific reason
that happens literally all the time yeah
because I told you I used to live in a
block of France Flats full of council
trash yeah yeah and this happens
every time I used to live in a council
estate full of tramps yeah we have
nothing better to do than yeah just
argue yeah so this stuff
happened every Wednesday yeah and it
happens all the all the time the mom
gets rid of the dad because he's busted
the new man comes in and the youth
starts calling them dad the next week
and everyone's like oh he's such a man
then the real deck comes in and it's
drama you are now either trying to get
rid of the the guy who's pretending to
play that yeah or you're trying to get
rid of the guy who
who actually is the dad or because their
mum's stressed that she's got are you
calling two-man dad because like she
can't say boundaries yeah it's like it's
damaging bro just like you can step up
and be involved in a kid's life and be a
father figure without this whole like
this is my you I am her dad I don't care
who's not made her this is mine and I'm
not leaving stuff like that's crazy it's
scary it was very scary it's crazy
and now he's sitting here stressed
thinking I'm not gonna have access yeah
where I'm sure you've already got you
that's in the yard that's yours yeah so
you're going to be seeing this you all
the time just take a step back
just come in and come out and just be
there to support and like Overlook and
make sure everyone's calm in the yard
that your kid lives in plus you've got
another you in there that you basically
are there dad even if you didn't claim
him as the dad you've been with them for
years so
like six years in total yeah minimum six
years yeah that's that's essentially
your kid and then you've got a kid
that really is your kid just just chill
just chill with all this Dad stuff it's
too much
I feel like it's um it's one of those
ones where I feel like he started off he
started off on like her on the wrong
foot
um because I feel like it's so uneven
when
you you meet a person and if if that
person already has a child and you don't
have a child or you're just living your
single life and you start to
build a relationship with that person
you already know there's going to be
some form of imbalance with just that
one child in the first place so if you
choose to let's say me for example I've
chosen to be with a woman that already
has a kid I've I've chosen to take on
any potential headache that comes my way
with this with this one kid yeah yeah I
then
you know what take this kid as my own I
want to procreate with my Missus and
have a kid with her okay we're a family
there's four of us now
I can't
I can't be so shocked
that
whether we if if and when we break up
that she's not gonna go and have another
kid with someone else purely because
not necessarily because it happened in
the past but I just didn't I don't know
what navigated her to want to have
want to have a kid with someone and
not potentially try and make that
workout with the First with the first
dad or the first um father and now that
she's
now that she's
clearly like broken up with me and gone
we've gone our separate ways
she's Revisited old habits and said oh I
didn't mean to not necessarily get
pregnant but I wish it was yours kind of
thing yeah chat is so telling of the old
her old self yeah bro what is all that
so I feel like
I'll use me as an example let Sam in his
shoes I've made the miss the initial
mistake of playing on an unlevel playing
field because if I wanted to I would
only pursue a relationship with a woman
that has a kid if I had a kid myself and
I was a single parent because I feel
like that's the only way we can mentally
understand how everything works and how
everything can balance out because it
just doesn't make sense in my opinion
any other way yeah so the fact that he
broke up or they actually broke up or
whatever and she got pregnant again by
someone else I would be pissed off but I
also want to be too surprised and it's
like yeah I've put myself in this
situation I have to try and now navigate
my way out of it in terms of what what
would I do I would do exactly what you
said James in terms of I've really got a
kid with her so I'm never to be honest
going still going to be going to this
house and still going to be seeing my
kid so I shouldn't have doubled down so
much and be like okay I'm gonna accept
this kid as my hair I'm gonna accept
this other kid is my life why are you
doing this this happy family thing when
you know for a fact it's not
it potentially there is no longevity in
it you know it's always a possibility
that homeboy is going to come into the
scene and it's also also a possibility
that when the kid gets older even if he
didn't come back the kid's going to want
to know that exactly so just full
transparency with what's going on what's
all this like ownership style stuff we
had um we had a zoom call a few months
ago and you remember the guy there was a
guy talking about were you in this chat
as well were in the zoom
there was a guy saying he got someone
pregnant and he said he wanted to do the
right thing so he just proposed to her
yeah this was the last one yeah he just
proposed to her but he was or he's
always on road and they both did their
separate things but it's like why are
you doubling down to propose to her just
because she got pregnant you can just
still be a dad yeah you know you don't
have to double like I feel like
sometimes
um people not even just men or women
people just make the wrong decisions in
like and make
they make the wrong decisions
in um how do I explain this
um just out of the moment do you know
what I mean In the Heat of the Moment
they're making the emotions are high
that's what I'm saying it's an emotional
yeah yeah an emotional they make a
decision on based on an emotional
situation instead of stepping out of it
and looking at it from a third person's
perspective and thinking logically yeah
that's what a lot of people do
especially like minuscule arguments let
alone like mother Brothers
it's tough but it's also easier said
than done it is I've said some when
I love boys yeah yeah I've said
something everyone has yeah everyone
says some where they love everyone
says some where they're angry
everyone says some when they're
feeling hateful whatever things happen
in the moment but I feel like
there are times as an adult you've got
to understand that praising a child
that's not your own I'm not saying
because it's not something I've ever
done but raising a child that's not your
own is always going to come with
complications as long as the father is
alive yeah yeah as long as the father is
alive it's gonna come for come with
complications so you've got to be
prepared for that regardless of the year
it comes do you know what I mean so yeah
like in the heat at the moment in the
sense of the relationship in order to
please the misses people would just say
yeah it yeah you're saying those
papers yeah bro this heart yeah this
it's all transparency boy the fact that
the the biggest point for me was when he
said
now we've broke up the father of the U
is involved even though she promised he
would never be yeah that's not normal
bro that's not why are you listening to
a woman that's telling you don't I
promise you this dad's never gonna get
involved why why did you get why do you
not what yeah why are you pregnant by
him you feel so certain he's never going
to be involved and also
caveat I don't know the guy but why are
you out here Banning people from being
involved in use facts who are you to
start Banning people so that's behavior
that I'm concerned May reflect on me
when we're not in a good place there we
go and now look where we are there we go
see it's one of them ones man I feel
like
it's tough because obviously you are in
a tough position but you also put
yourself in that position as well it's
it's hard to navigate you sounded like
you ignored a lot of red flags he did
and that's why I'm saying it's
is sometimes easy not necessarily easy
to ignore but like easy to put on the
back burner because you think it's not
going to bite you until like x amount of
years time yeah and then when that that
time comes you're like what do I
have yeah to be fair he's full of red
flags as well what do you mean three
months into relationship he's claiming
next to you again red flag bear red
flags out here this whole dilemma's a
red flag doesn't say you put yourself in
a situation so it's hard to give you
advice when
I'm really trying not to cuss him it's
hard to give him advice
long story short when you do dumb
yeah yeah because you just gotta
around and find out fat and that's
what's happened man farts around and you
finally she around yeah I found
out let's move with some Decor or Quorum
and Common Sense yeah common sense it's
common sense is the one like yeah let's
not claim use that we just we've just
met literally just met yeah let's not
ignore red flags when women say I'm
praying about next man but I promise you
he's never gonna see this you that's
that's scary boss easy talk yeah that's
crazy
so what happens God forbid we break up
am I never gonna see more yeah exactly
is that what you were telling me yeah
that's why she's gonna cut me out
because she makes threats she makes
physical threats yeah I hope it works
out but I've got no more advice yeah
just stop doing what you're doing bro
actual bro take a step back raise your
own child your son or daughter and yeah
just keep the pep step in because yeah
just try and be a father figure for
everyone yeah without claiming and
owning people all the time because now
you can't backtrack because you've
claimed the first
[Applause]
my mother-in-law babysat our kids while
we went on a cruise
I left her my ATM card for expenses
we returned and all hell broke loose she
found our weed and reported us to the
police for having drugs in the house
with miners at home wow bro
DCFS which I'm assuming is some drug
Federal Services yeah yeah yeah DC
Department of Child Department oh yeah
Department of Children
all right cool DCFS is now involved
because drugs were found in our home
yeah she found my firearm in my lock box
and told police having a gun violated
her son's parole
and
and he was in the uh and he was in the
Bahamas also parole violation yeah yeah
yeah my husband was arrested when we
landed at the airport on top of all that
my mother-in-law took 1500 out of my
account for babysitting my husband
forgave his mother but I can't
she calls and visits as if all is well
tamish is a snake and wants to take our
kids what do I do oh my how has he
forgiven his mother bro she said it's a
pen how has he forgiven wait who was it
their weed or his weed or her weed first
of all there we it's their weed so
you're and her god wow
wow wow wow wow wow
I would denounce her as my mother oh
gender is here literally like I know
you're trying to do a Good Samaritan but
at what cost all the cost at what cost
big man I am your son I'm getting sent
to jail because of you like actually
you're coming to my yard next week or
wherever whenever just to play with you
just to play with and everything's fine
and she's just coming up there sorry but
the law is the Lord what do you mean the
say less the law is the law I I
guarantee you if I sign up
really did because I know you've got
some skeletons back yeah religious
that's really big that's really
dick because you want to start sending
man to pen yeah you can do this yeah if
we're sending people to pen let's send
people to pen we can really do this
because it's the love of my life in my
house yeah yeah and my children my
children I don't play when it comes to
my children I don't play with my
family like that now DCFS I might be
like that no I don't play my family like
that I'm sorry I couldn't forgive her
yeah double parole violation
yeah
being arrested as soon as I laughed yeah
there's feds wave you getting off your
flight to find your mom snitched I
wouldn't know what to believe I wouldn't
know what way I would tell you man you
men are lying to me yeah yeah I was like
tell me the truth I know I'm arrested
but tell me the truth
I'm talking about my mom like that tell
me who told you
tell me you told you wow
and then you see your mom walking past
the office
nah I was scream bro
they should just come and say it's all
right I had to you know I had to it's
the law the children what am I supposed
to do what are you supposed to do by the
way I took 1500
those are my feet yeah there's my feet
ah I would have to build my dad I will
bail him
what do you tell me about her what's
going on those are my fees bro nah like
I wouldn't be able to get the words
actual thing is you'd have to send me to
pen yeah yeah you have to send me to pen
then and there I'll just raise my hands
yeah
I rate because I wouldn't know what to
believe
to send me to pen because I need to call
off I need somewhere to fall off and it
couldn't be somewhere I know yeah yeah
yeah it's I'd have to call off oh that's
the funniest thing I've heard it's the
funniest thing I've heard bro wow wow
I've not seen that dilemma all right
gang right before we finish I've got one
more thing I hit me it's just like some
random breakdown that made me laugh okay
right cool
my drunk ass girlfriend said she had sex
with her with over 200 guys
she said
um she said she was a real back in
college and it made me stop and think
I think I've seen you see this is that
like a mathematics yeah yeah the
algorithm bro four years of college
times 365 days a year yeah 200 guys
equals a new guy every 7.3 days Jesus
since she said 200 uh well rounded off a
new guy every seven days yeah every
seven days yeah given that she had sex
with a guy on average of three times and
an average dick length of 5.5 inches and
about a hundred thrusts to knock
we're looking at a hundred thrust times
three per guy times 11 inches which is
5.5 inches and in 5.85 inches out
Jesus 3 300 inches of dick per week
3 300 inches of dick times 208 weeks is
000 inches of dick that's
10.45 miles of big miles I got in my car
and drove 10.45 miles and thought about
dicks being laid end to end and that's
how much dish she's taken she's not my
girlfriend anymore oh my bro
I feel like I read that my eyes wide
yeah but I feel like it's one of them
ones where
yes we've got an open relationship but
there's some stuff just don't tell me
you can't tell me that you can't tell me
you were a touring College hundred man
that is three times per man that's Unix
what is is to each their road yeah yeah
but my own is unacceptable yeah your
your body all rules yeah your body all
rules but to me it's unacceptable yeah
because Islam you know what I mean
Fox
when I die I Need My Virgins yeah and
this ain't gonna get us there yeah we're
not patterning heaven yeah we're clearly
not patting in heaven and it's it's a
healthy yeah yeah yeah and I'm not going
down
literally I need we need to go our
separate ways because I need to see the
party yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
because this is my mad 10 miles point to
point of 10 miles end to end of
pipe wow 200 guys
who's keeping count by the way that will
concern me the most yeah she's kept
count she's kept scoring she's kept
scores bro because I'm like
I was a in college as well and I
lost counts yeah and I actively tried
taking account I think we all did yeah
we all did and I lost it yeah yeah after
like 40. yeah I was like I don't know
anymore I don't even know their names
I don't know anymore I just stopped
counting there's no way she remembers
all their names there's no chance she
remembers all their names and if she
does that's concern oh that's the most
concerning thing of all time if she does
that is concerning she said I was a real
back in college that's it's yeah
it's not girlfriend material but if it's
a first date yeah
that's a pretty tick right here
if we're doing up dirty martini yeah she
said she's getting a bit loose and
confidence
oh God it's so embarrassing
[Laughter]
[Applause]
201 how about that oh God that's funny
bro but yeah damn right wrapping it up
wrapping it up let's do it guys that was
Sensational it was as always catch us on
Thursday patreon.com
a day join the cult babies make your
daddy's happy and do not forget
Wednesdays Wednesdays Subs go over right
now with now that we're done facts go
over to the reaction Channel And
subscribe subscribe to that we
need to see five figure Subs minimum she
doesn't just reacts go there yeah
immediately immediately yeah yeah thank
you guys
[Music]
thank you